mds joins us now super bowl 55 in the
rearview mirror but it's time to hand
out awards we've got five categories
today there's mds we're gonna get right
into it with call of the game for super
bowl five five mds you're up first
well i'm gonna go with the buccaneers
going for it on that fourth and one
where of course they got stopped ronald
jones got stuffed at the goal line
didn't get in but it led to a series of
possessions where the chiefs couldn't
get very far backed up deep in their own
territory shanked the punt given the
buccaneers great field position and then
the buck scored a touchdown and i just
think that shows why you should always
go for it on fourth and goal from the
one because even if you get stopped
you're backing the other team up in
terrible field position you're going to
take over in good field position most
likely in the long run playing the field
position game it works to go for it on
fourth and goal from the one yes with
the touchdown the bucks had right before
the end of the first half i just thought
that was huge ten seconds left no
timeouts they're at the one yard line
and you say all right well they trust
tom brady but i thought back to that
patriots chiefs game in in early october
and the chiefs had the ball at the i'm
sorry they were at the cheese 13 the
patriots were they were traveling six to
three and brian warrior takes that sack
of frank clark they get no points out of
it that was huge you trust tom brady ab
runs the wrong route they still get the
touchdown now it's 21-6 at the half that
was huge almost exactly what they did in
the nfc championship game against the
packers scottie miller scores with one
second left and they're up 21-10 both of
those games were over at halftime mike
and setting the stage for that touchdown
by antonio brown was the scottie miller
type call sending mike evans deep with
40 wait 44-24 it was 44 seconds i think
24 seconds after they got the first down
the clock was running the chiefs had
taken those two timeouts they sent mike
evans deep and he draws the past
interference foul from bashad breeland i
think there was a little bit of acting
not a ton it wasn't a full-blown soccer
flop but there was some embellishment as
mike evans went to the ground he drew
the flag and it set the buccaneers up
where they could get it into the end
zone and there is a huge difference in
my mind between 17 to 6 and 21 to 6 and
definitely a huge difference between 21
and 14. if the bucks don't score on that
drive and they were aided by the two
timeouts taken by the chiefs if they
don't score on that drive chiefs get the
ball first to start the second half
one drive down the field two point
conversion if they choose to do it then
makes it 14 all and we got a brand new
ball game all right next x factor for
super bowl 55 mds who you got
well i have tristan wirtz the rookie
offensive tackle who was so good in this
game
but really good throughout the season
and the playoffs and i don't think
got enough credit and in fact i'll go so
far as to say
if we were doing offensive rookie of the
year voting right now
including the playoffs i think i would
take tristan works over either justin
herbert or justin jefferson of course
neither of whom got a chance to bolster
their resumes in the playoffs herbert
and jefferson were the only two players
who got any offensive rookie of the year
votes but wurps was just outstanding he
was great in the super bowl very good
all season long especially as a pass
blocker and
i really thought deserved more credit
than he got for how well the buccaneers
offense played in super bowl sunday i'm
going to go with byron leftwich mds and
we saw in the clip to open the show
somebody thought he was todd bowles todd
bowles is getting all the love and
rightfully so for holding the chiefs to
nine points but i think we need to at
least throw a bouquet the way of buyer
leftwich because he was fantastic in
calling this game 31 points 340 yards
and you know if the hiring process mike
had begun this week as a lot of people
have proposed pushing it back the bucks
may be looking for two new new
coordinators this week
yeah absolutely because leftwich who got
no interviews would definitely get some
consideration and todd bowles who did
have some interviews
quite possibly would have ended up
getting a job and and i'll go with todd
bowles as the x factor and it's a
no-brainer for me i
what he did to deviate from the game
plan that failed in week 12 using a game
plan and getting his guys in the right
mindset to implement the game plan in
the super off and we'll put him on that
short list for next year the question is
if the buccaneers should regress next
year if the buccaneers end up
seven and nine
nate i'm just saying yeah yeah we don't
know what's going to happen from one
year to the next if they don't make the
playoffs or if they're just one and done
or something like that don't win the
division just aren't very aren't what
they were this year will people just
assume that all of a sudden todd bowles
doesn't know how to coach it really is
amazing how timing how positioning
yourself at the right moment gets you a
job
when you know a down year well the guy
that we thought was a genius in february
now is in a genius in late december it's
kind of strange how that works but bowls
for me was the key to that victory for
the tampa bay buccaneers all right stat
of the game mds you're up
my stat was patrick mahomes with a
career low
52.3 passer rating worst he's ever had
in any game and you know he was just
running for his life
all game long he didn't get a lot of
help from his wide receivers he
struggled in this game like no other
game since he's been
in the nfl uh obviously still has an
outstanding future ahead of him but it
was really remarkable i thought that
this was just the first time we've ever
watched the chiefs with patrick mahomes
and said boy he just can't do anything
they they've got him in this game um it
speaks to what you said if todd bowles
having such a good game and also just it
was just a down game all around for that
chief's offense
i'm gonna go with the 22 point margin of
victory for the bucks in this game and
if you go back to tom brady's previous
six super bowl
wins not surprisingly i'm a journalist
so my math wasn't that good yesterday i
forgot the 10-point win that tom brady
had over the rams so his previous margin
of victory for the six games was
actually 29 points not 19 as i said
yesterday but it was still close 29
points for those six 22 uh for this one
the previous blow out with the ten point
margin of victory over the rams they'd
all been close super bowls mike until
this one for tom brady this one was not
close
i kind of swore in one of those photos
becky who is a patriots fan i it just
what in the world's going on here all
right um
never mind apologize i'm getting a phone
call uh
i i thought i had my ringer off um all
right next one for me
the patrick mahomes stat of the yardage
that he ran or mileage that he ran
behind the line of scrimmage before
throwing the ball or getting sacked this
came from next-gen stats and it came to
our attention from seth walter 497
yards
before his passes or sacks
in the
super bowl just amazing and it was the
highest of the season second place was
495 by mahomes in week five against the
raiders another game that the chiefs
lost but with that bad toe to run that
far before throwing the ball or getting
sacked incredible incredible that he was
able to do it and do it as well as he
was all right missed opportunity time
super bowl 55 mds go
well the chiefs kicked the field goal on
fourth and goal just a minute before
halftime and i think that was a big
mistake they should have gone for it
there because if you score a touchdown
you're right back in the game even if
you fail to convert you're going to pin
the buccaneers deep they probably play
it safe and just go into halftime there
instead
after the chiefs kick the field goal the
buccaneers got a good return on the
ensuing kickoff marched right down the
field scored a touchdown before halftime
ended up extending their lead by four
points compared to where it was before
the chiefs kicked that field goal and
you know i mentioned earlier i liked
bruce arians going for it on a fourth
down even though he didn't do it even
though he didn't get it
this is a time when i don't like andy
reid kicking the field goal even though
the field goal was good in that
situation they really should have gone
forward on fourth down
and mds we always talk about teams
doubling up when they're going to get
the kickoff to start the second half the
chiefs had a chance to double up their
they didn't they lost points they come
out to open the second half and they
settle for another field goal and now
the play calling to me on that drive was
not good clyde edwards hillary goes
for runs of 21 and 10 yards on two of
the four first three plays of that drive
they don't give him the ball again they
stall out they kick the field goal huge
difference there too that they get the
field goal and not the touchdown
yeah and look another decision that was
a missed opportunity for the chiefs we
talked about this earlier on that last
buccaneers drive and when the buccaneers
got the ball back with 105 to go if i
get that what are they going to do run
the ball a couple of times you're too
far away from the end zone
surely they're not going to try to drive
down the field and score and then kansas
city starts calling timeouts first down
i get it relenting for that went nowhere
take the time out maybe get a chance to
get the ball back and do the bill
belichick double dip get a score near
the end of the half and score to start
the third quarter but when they gain
eight yards on the second down play make
a third and two and the chiefs take the
time out
that's starting to make me a little more
nervous and what happened they get the
first down boom the ball goes down the
field to mike evans the play we talked
about earlier and
one domino falls after another and the
next thing you know the uh buccaneers
are up 21-6 going in to the half all
right
another category special category for
this one because tom brady was named the
mvp of the game we have decided to name
the real mvp of the game because all
three of us agree that it shouldn't have
been tom brady mds who do you think it
should have been
well i really like the game turned in by
vida veya who we weren't even expecting
to see again when he broke his leg in
october but he was outstanding and he
had the kind of impact that doesn't show
up much in the stats he's not the guy
who gets a lot of sacks gets a lot of
tackles for loss but what he is is the
guy who can he can just push a center or
a guard straight back into patrick
mahomes face i thought there were a lot
of plays when patrick mahomes the reason
he escaped the pocket as you mentioned
having to run around so much behind the
line i thought vida veya was the guy who
got the first push that made patrick
mahomes say okay i can't stand in the
pocket i got to make a play with my legs
here and that was just the theme of the
game that that inside pressure was
really getting to patrick mahomes i
thought vida veya for a guy who we
thought was done for the season coming
back and making that kind of impact was
very impressive
well let me just say first i know what
it feels like now to be florio to pick
third like he did the whole entire year
you get the scraps right so i would have
voted for one of the two guys if i had
an mvp vote which i have before i would
have voted for one of the two guys that
that you guys have but i did think that
there were 11 players on that defense
that you could have picked and antoine
winfield had a great game when you
consider what they did in week 12
against patrick mahomes giving up 462
yards they come back in this game give
up 270 to mahomes and intercept him
twice and he had one of those
interceptions and i think we need a
shout out too to levante david for the
job that he did on travis kelsey that
was just a great defensive performance
mike that the buccaneers had all the way
across the line
and you had your chance you had your
opportunity there was a grace period you
had to go out for your one hour walk in
the 22 degree wind chill that you know
we
mds and i
really feel sorry for you given that
like mds said he would kill for a 22
degree wind chill right now in chicago
devin white was my choice i tweeted it
during the game devin white should be
the mvp it wasn't going to happen but he
was the guy that that
and and also if they did it like they do
it in hockey
where it's a full postseason mvp is it
the con smith is that the trophy
something tells me it is um it is a it
is the const might blind squirrel eats
acorn but but it would have been devin
white right for the full playoffs it was
devon white and and i wish that that he
would have gotten more consideration i
don't know how much he ultimately got
but it's tom brady and he had three
touchdown passes it's hard to overcome
that without at least a pick six or a
fumble recovery for a touchdown all
right mds great stuff
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports